so like any crop kinata um harvests
energy from the Sun carbon dioxide from
the air water from the soil and that
allows it to create yield for us to use
but it also returns carbon into the soil
sequestering it there so that uh it's
permanently in the soil or it's
available for a future crop to use our
goal with the growing system of kinata
is to grow kinata in situations where
you normally wouldn't have a crop so
it's a non-f food acre an acre where
nothing would be grown kinata goes in
that place harvests that energy from the
Sun Harvest CO2 from the air creates
yield for us to create biofuels other
oil type products and also returns
carbon into the soil making it a net
negative carbon
crop